[Music]
I saw it was amazing it's really well
done really nice to launch well Lindsay
Lohan approves of ariana grande's Mean
Girls tribute in her thank you next
music video last night Lindsay
celebrated the premiere of her MTV show
Lohan's Beach Club but before that we
also chatted about the comedy classic
and how she hoped to make fetch happen
with a sequel that is so fetch Gretchen
stop trying to make fetch happen cool
this year marks the 15th anniversary of
Mean Girls 15 years oh my gosh seemingly
still to me it feels like it was
yesterday
well Jonathan Lacy amazing they've all
said they're down I love those
characters I think it would be so fun to
revisit this movie is such an iconic
movie I'm in for it I think we're all
willing right oh it'd be so much fun it
would be great if I don't make this hat
I don't know maybe we'll have to like
protestin Lindsay's life today well
she's worth a reported eight hundred
thousand compare that to the nearly 30
million she was worth in the mean girls
days but lilo is making a comeback
20 years repair trap 20 years yes thanks
for minding me I know okay I'm about to
blow your mind even more okay this is
your very first o-t interview you really
want to be a big big star yeah it's fun
and I like the attention you still talk
to Samson oh my god when you look at
that girl though what would you tell her
20 years later keep living in New York
right now she lives in Dubai and when we
met at New York serendipity 3 lilo told
me life abroad may explain why she talks
indifferent and sometimes confusing
accents the paparazzi may be across the
street I didn't know you can go out you
can have a nice
you don't have to dream her I think when
I'm around certain dialects it changes
each time you pick things up along the
way
[Music]
[Applause]